よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマは「無我」という言葉でございます
無我は パーリ語で anattā (アナッター) という言葉を使っています
anattā という言葉の意味は
永遠不滅な 変化しない実体は 見当たらないという意味なんですね
いわゆる否定形で 実体はない という意味なんですね
いわゆる 無実体論 というよりは 非実体
実体ではない という意味なんです
無我について直接話し始めると
結構難しい話にはなります
2回目は 来月でしょうか？
いろいろ経典から いくらか引用して
例を出して 説明したいと思っています
今日は 一般的なお話にいたします
特に私は 単に この無我について 喋りたいという気持ちはございませんが
無我についてよりは 違うテーマに変えてみたいんですね
なぜ人間は そう簡単には覚りを開けないかと
仏教の世界では
一生懸命修行している人々は 結構いるんですね
昔から今まで
それは 南方仏教とかね
北伝仏教とか
関係なく どなたでも
大変真面目に 必死になって修行しているんです
修行のやり方が 少々変わっても
やっぱり目的は同じで
誰でも なんとか 覚りを開きたい気持ちはあるんですね
で あるんですけど
なかなか 覚った人々の数は少ないんです
お釈迦様さえも 人が覚りを開いたら
「これは大変珍しいことや」と 褒めるんですね
それで お釈迦様は 覚りを開いた人々のことを 特別に褒めてあげる
「偉大なる人々ですよ」と
「勝利者ですよ」と
世の中の 何ものにもとらわれない
何と言いますか
動物に例えたら 「ライオンのような人ですよ」と
「象のような人ですよ」と
「堂々たる人々ですよ」と
それから「聖なる人々ですよ」と
「この世の中で聖者というならば 覚った人だけですよ」と
「何の借りもなく この世の中で 生きている人々ですよ」
そういういろいろな言葉で 覚った人のことをお釈迦様は説明しています
いわゆる 褒めているんですね
なぜそんなに褒めたかというと
やっぱり 覚る人々の数が少なかったからなんです
で 仏典なんかね
仏典は 経典だけではなくて
いろいろな仏典がたくさんありますから
その場合は ガンジス川の砂のように人々は覚ったとか
ああだこうだとか 言ってますけどね
ああいうのは事実ではなくて
文学的な表現ですね
それを真面目に 事実として
ガンジス川にある砂を数えて
それぐらい人が覚ったかどうかと聞くのは 何の意味もないんです
ただ そんな大事な経典を聞いて 誰もわからなかったと言ってしまったら
なんか ちょっと格好がつきませんからね
で それぐらい人々は覚りましたとかね
それは大乗経典でも
初期仏教　経典ではなくて
初期仏教仏典でも
そういうふうに たくさん人々が
覚りましたと
それから 仏教でよく使う便利な数字があります
それは 八万四千ですね
何かお経を お釈迦様が説法なさったならば
その説法を聞いて  84,000人の人々は覚りましたと
そういうと 説法を 10回ぐらいしたならば
84,000人 かける 10だから
インドの人口 みんな覚ってしまいますね
当時では そんなに人口がいたわけじゃないし
また お釈迦様は 南の方にいらっしゃったわけでもないし
ですから そういうのは あくまでも文学的な表現であって
そんなに たくさん覚ったわけじゃないんです
お釈迦様が 自分が最初に説法した時
「初転法輪経」という名前をつけていますけど
その説法が終わったところで
コンダンニャ(Koṇḍañño)という お釈迦様の 5人の比丘たちの長老ですね
彼だけ たったひとりだけ 真理を理解したんですね
いわゆる第1番目のステージに覚ったんですね
お釈迦様はすごく喜んだんです
すごく喜んだんです
あれほど 6年間も修行して それは無駄になって
それから いろいろな人に説法しましたよ
何人かに説法しましたけど
あまり わからなくなったし
それで この5人の 自分の古い友達
まぁ 友達でもあるし お釈迦様が在家の時
自分の宮殿にいた 家来の方々でもありましたし
その 5人のひとりが理解したことで 大変喜びました
なぜかというと それぐらい難しいことなんですね
お釈迦様にしてみれば
ひとりでもわかったことは 不思議なことなんですね
ですから Aññāsi vata bho Koṇḍañño!
Aññāsi vata bho Koṇḍañño!
「コンダンニャだけは理解しました」
「コンダンニャに わかりました」と
すぐ喜びの言葉を お話しなさっているんですね
で そこまで言ったのは
覚るということは なかなか難しいこと
そこで その5人の比丘たちの
コンダンニャ大長老が理解しました
それからお釈迦様は つきっきりで
残りの4人に 授業をなさったんです
ずっと
それで ずっと説法したところで
ひとり ふたり 4人 それで 5人
こういうふうに ゆっくり覚っていったんですね
覚っても完全ではなくて
覚りは 我々はステージを４つに分けてますからね
第1番目のステージですね
「預流果」というんですけどね
そこまで覚ったんですね
それでお釈迦様が みんなを連れて行って
5人に すごい大胆な ひとつのお経を 説法したんですね
その大胆な説法は 無我についてなんです
で そこまで 無我という言葉を あまり使ってなかったんですね
後で やっぱりこの4人は 一部はわかったんだけど
完全に煩悩は断ち切っていない
まだ煩悩は いくつか残っている
お釈迦様と同等になっていない
覚りの立場から見れば
それはよくないんですね
お釈迦様は 自分が覚った状況と全く同じに
みんなに理解して欲しかったんですからね
そこで どこで引っかかっているんですか と
わかったところで
無我ですよ と
という経典を 今 経典にはなってますけど
そういう説法をなさったんですね
本当は 長い時間をかけて 説法をなさったと思いますけど
経典自体は そんなに長いものではないんです
出典を言っても 僕はパーリ版のページしか持ってないのでね
日本の訳はちょっとわかりませんし
イギリス版の第3
サンユッタニカーヤというテキストにね
第3番目の 67〜68 ページ
ページは ふたつしかないんですけどね
その経典の名前は Anattalakkhaṇa という名前なんですね
anattāについて 無我について お話をしました
それで 無我についてお話をしたところで
5人も 阿羅漢になってしまったんですね
いわゆる 完全に覚ってしまったんですね
それからも説法をなさって 60人が増えたんです
60人の覚った人々が増えたんですね
増えたところで 伝道開始ですね
こういう幸福な道を みんなに教えてくださいと
今 世の中で覚った人々が 61人いるんだと
私も あなた方も 煩悩はなくなっているんだと
で 心は清らかになっているんだと
完全たる解脱を得ているんだと
ですから やることはないんだからね　これからは
ですから 人々が苦しんでいるんだから
人々の幸福のために
幸せのために
ひとりひとりで歩いて 教えてあげてくださいと
世界初の伝道活動ですね
人類初
それで仏教を どんどん広げていきました
とにかく 大事なポイントは
覚らない この引っ掛けは ここにあると
無我というところにあるわけじゃなくて
「無我と言わなきゃダメですよ」ということなんです
「実体はない」と
だから 実体はないというと ちょっと強烈なんですけど
漢字をいじってみると やっぱり 非実体 と言わなくちゃいけないんですね
いわゆる 存在否定しているわけではないんです
実体はありません と言ったら
なんとなく ちょっと否定したようになっちゃいますけど
ですから この非実体の
物事の 非実体的な本質を説明したんです
そこで 大乗仏教に馴染みのある方々は よく知っている言葉がありまして
「空」 という言葉が
空という言葉は パーリ語で suñña (スンニャ) というんですね
サンスクリット語だったら śūnya (シューニャ)というふうになりますけど
非実体であること　存在は
すべては非実体であることを
śūnya 空だと お釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
でも「śūnya 空ですよ」と言い続けちゃうと
また 論理的に 道徳的に いろいろトラブルを起こしちゃうんですね
ですから それほど使ってないんです
一般的に同義語として
無我の同義語として śūnya という言葉を使っているんです
śūnya というのは 空ということなんですね
ですから 私は今日
śūnya あるいは 空について 喋っているんだと思っても構いませんし
あるいは 無我について 喋っているんだと思っても構いませんし
じゃあ そこまで いくらか
一般的な話で それから
なんで これに 引っかかってるかというところから
なんでそんな考え方が
世の中にあるんですか とか
そこら辺をちょっと話したいんです
anattāは 否定形で
肯定系の言葉は attā なんですね
それはパーリ語で attā と言うんです
サンスクリット語で ātman (アートマン)と言うんですね
ātman
お釈迦様から見ると
人々は この ātman
ātman あるいは「我」
あるいは 「実体」というものは あるんだと
人類の初期時代から そういうふうに思い込んでいたんですね
何か実体があるんだ
その実体も 永遠不滅なもので
変わらないものだと思っていたんです
そこで 私たちに何か永遠不滅なものがあると思うと
我々はそれにしがみついて つかまっていかなくちゃ いけないんですね
それで すごく それにすがって
自分の ātmanに 自分の実体に
自分の本心に
徹底的に 縛りつけてもらって
いなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
それは 解脱という言葉の 全く反対のことなんですね
解脱というのは 一切を捨てるという意味なんです
何にもとらわれません
そこで ātman ということ
自我のことを喋る場合は
やっぱり自我だけは本心だから 本物だから
それだけは否定するな ということになっちゃうんですね
ですから 自我を信じることで 煩悩は消えなくなっちゃうんですね
心は きれいにならなくなっちゃうんですね
解脱は不可能になっちゃうんですね
そういうわけで 自分の5人の友人たちに
大胆に 「何も自我というものはないんですよ」と
「どこにもないんですよ」 ということで
お釈迦様の 2番目の説法
まぁ 有名な説法として 2番目を教えたんです
じゃあ それから一般的に 我々はその問題を考えてみましょう
私たちにも この自我という概念はあるんです
ないわけないんです
もしどなたかが 「私は仏教だから 自我を信じていません」と
「ātman を信じていません」 と言っても
それは嘘なんです
まぁ 信じていないかもしれませんけど
やっぱり 心では あると思っているんです
もし ないとわかったら
その人は 覚っているんです
だから それはもう そういうことで
どんな偉大なる仏教の人であろうとも
やっぱり覚ってないならば 「自我はあるんだ」と
頑固と しがみついているんですね
ですから 覚れない引っ掛けは そこにあるんです
ですから 私は 自我 無我 のことを説明すると
皆様が それを覚って 終わるか
あるいは 全く理解しないか
どっちかにはなりますけど
だから 中途半端で説明しようかなと
「どのように 自我論が生まれるのでしょうか？」 と考えてみましょう
人間というのは 大体
生きていると ものは見ていると
すぐ頭の中では 「私は見ているんだ」 という概念が生まれる
何か聞いていると 「あぁ 私が聞いているんだ」と 概念が生まれる
香りが鼻に入ると 「あぁ 私は嗅いでいるんだ」と
口に味が入ると 「私は味わっているんだ」と
体にいろんなものが触れると
冷たさ 熱さ 硬さ 柔らかさやらね
「あ 私は感じているんだ」と思うんですね
そこで 目でものが見えたら
まぁ 時々喜びを感じる
「あ 美しい」と 「きれい」と
耳から入る音についても
人間は 喜びを感じる
そのように我々の五根から
人間 まぁ 時たま喜びを感じる
ずっとではないんだけど
それから 物事を考える
その考えるものについても
時々面白いものを考えたりする
それと 喜びを感じたりする
そこで 人間が見たり 聞いたり
考えたり 味わったり 嗅いだり
触れたりするものについて
「あぁ いいものや」 と
生きているということは すごく楽しくて 素晴らしいものだと 思っちゃうんですね
なんて幸せかと
昔だったらね
森の中に入って 獲物でも取れたら
なんて幸せかと みんな大変 大喜びをしました
今の人々も もうそれなりに何か獲得したら
「なんて私は幸せだろう」と
というふうに 思ったりする
そこで 「自分がいる」と 錯覚が生まれるんです
「私は考える ですから 私がいる」と
錯覚が生まれるんですね
だから 屁理屈です
「私が考えている 故に私がいる」 ということは屁理屈です
なぜならば 最初からもう 「私は」を入れているんだから
証拠もなしに
だから 故に私がいる と言えないんです
それは 違う例えで言えば
「ここに牛がいる だから牛がいる」と
何の意味もないんです
「ここに牛がいる」と言ったら
もう牛がいるんです だからいりません
だから 「私が考える 故に私がいる」は
完全にもう屁理屈の始まりなんですね
だから 仏教的に言えば
「考える」という働きがある
正しく見れば「考える というファンクション 働きがある 故に私がいる」と言えないんです
その場合は
なぜならば
「私がいなかったら 働きがないよ」ということを まず証明しなくちゃいけないんですね
「私は考えているんじゃないか だからいるんだ」と
というのは あまりにも もう幼稚的な
ガキ的な考え方なんですね
でも 人間は そんなに頭がいいわけじゃないし
ただ簡単 単純に 「私が見ている」
「私が聞いている」「私が考えている」と 思って
どこにでも 「私が」という言葉が出てくるんですね
そこでまとめて 「私がいるんだ」と 結論付けちゃう
最初からもう 「私が見る」ということは 解釈していないんです
そこら辺に 問題があるんですね
最初からもう 「私が見る」は問題です
それで 仏教で因果法則
認識論というものは できてきて
そこで どのように「私が見る」という錯覚が生まれるかと
そのプロセスを 仏教で説明しているんです
そこで 世の中の哲学は どのようになったかというと
「私がいる」の「私」が どのようなものかと考えたりする
すでに存在している すでにここにある自我が どのような自我でしょうか？
それは青いですか？ 赤いですか？とか インド人は考えたんです
自分の ātman が
ある宗派では ātman は青いですか？ 赤いですか？ 白いですか？ 黄色いですか？ と 色を7つに分けたんです
そこで 完全に心を清らかにした人のātman が 白い色で
仏教の人の ātman が すごい ひどい色なんですね
なんか ものすごい 黒い 青い色なんですね
で 仏教でない ヒンドゥー教とか
他の宗教の人は 黄色いとかね
赤いとか 白い色に近いんです
で それはその通りで
仏教では 無我と言っているんだから
仏教の人々の ātman の色は 黒いと言ってもしょうがないんです
その人から見れば ātmanを否定しているんだから
だから 人間が何をやったかというと
ātman について 考えたんです
自我について考えたんであって
自我は あるかないかとは 確かめなかったんですね
どのように この自我という錯覚が生まれたかどうかは 探してないんです
それは わかりやすい例で言えば
誰かから 我々は例えば 聞くんです
どこかのところに 空き家があるんだと
「その空き家には お化けが出るんだ」と聞いたら
「あぁ そうですか 」と
そうだったら そのお化けは こういうものだと喋るんです
それで もうひとりは 「いやいや そんなお化けがいるわけじゃない」
こんな感じでお化けがいるんだと
これ いくら喋っても無意味なんです
まず 本当に その空き家に お化けが出るか出ないかと
確かめなきゃ 何の意味もないんです
ですから 仏教では 合理的だったら 厳密に合理的になりましょうと
具体的だったら 厳密に具体的になりましょう ということで
具体的に 厳密に その問題を扱っているんです
それで 昔の人々から見れば
まぁ ここに自分がいるんじゃないかと
それから自分がいるんだけど
やっぱり自分に 好きなこともあるし
嫌なこともあるし
で どんどん年取って 死んでしまうんですね
それはすごい惜しいことで
死にたくはないんです
なぜならば 目で見るものに囚われている
「あぁ 綺麗だ 」と
耳で聞くものに 「あぁ 美しいんだ」と
だから 人間は 生きていきたいというよりは
食べていきたい ものを見ていきたい
それだけのことなんです
「なんで そんなにも生きたがりますか？」と聞いたら
誰も考えてないんです
ただ「死にたくない」というだけで
よく見ると 人間というのは ものを 見続けたい
音を 聞き続けたい
味を 味わい続けたい
香りを 嗅ぎ続けたい
体でいろんなものを 触ったり 触れたりしたい ただそれだけ
ただ「生きていきたい」だけだったら
なんで 年取ると悩むんですかね？
「耳が遠くなった 大変だ」とか 悩む必要はない
生きているんだから それで十分でしょうに
「腰が 膝が痛くなって もう歩けないんだ 大変だ」とかね
あっちこっち 走り回る必要ないんです
歩かなくても 生きているんだから 「それでいいでしょう」と言えるんだけど
やっぱり それでいいわけじゃないんです
やっぱり歩いたり ものを見たり
考えたり 聞いたり 喋ったりしたいんです
ですから 生きていきたいという気持ちは
ただ見たい 聞きたい 嗅ぎたい
味わいたい 触れたい 感じたい
考えたい ということなんです
で 死ぬと それはできなくなっちゃうし
死ぬのは そういうわけで嫌なんですね
それも理解してほしい
なんか大雑把で 「やっぱり人間 誰でも死ぬのは嫌ですよ」
とか
「生命 誰でも 死ぬのは嫌ですよ」と 大雑把で言っても
それは はっきりした真理じゃないんです
誰でも 食べ続けたいと
食い続けたいと
だから 死にたくないと
もし人が 食べるものに飽きてしまったならば
聞く音に飽きてしまったならば
見ることにも飽きちゃったと
それだったら 元気がなくなって死んじゃうんです
それで とにかく人が死んでしまう
死んでしまうことは あまり好きじゃないんだから
やっぱり この「私」は 死ぬわけじゃないと
それに ちょっとした証拠はあるんです
我々は小さい時から いろんなことを覚えているんですね
いろんなこと 全部じゃないんです
そこで 「私は5歳で こういうことをしました」
「10歳で こういうことをしました」という
そんな素晴らしいメモリーじゃないんだけど
ちょっといい加減で
なんか はっきりしないんですけど
いくらかは 我々には記憶力はありますね
その記憶力で 我々は言葉で 「私は」という言葉で全部つなげちゃうんです
「私は 学校に行きました」と
「私は今 会社に行っているんだ」と
あれは嘘です
学校に行ったのは 子どもであって
あんた 今 おじいさんでしょうし
おじいさんたちは 学校に行かないのは 事実なんですけど
「え？ 私はなんとか学校に行きましたよ」と
平気で言うんです 嘘なのに
で そう言うのは
我々のわずかな記憶力と
この言葉
「私は」という言葉で 全部まとめるからなんです
それから 人間に もうひとつ見えるんですね
世の中を見ていると
なんか 自分勝手というよりは
世界を見ると ある一定の法則で
動いているんではないかと
人間には なかなかどうしようもないんです
世の中を見ると 何か一定の法則があるんですね
その一定の法則というものは
例えば 米が欲しい人は
リンゴの種をまいても 米は出てこないんですね
米が欲しい人は 大事に 自分の倉庫に
籾を持っていって 保存しても 全然増えません
彼がそれを持って 古くならないうちに
1年以内の籾を
水田に ちゃんとまいておかないと 稲が出てこないんですね
それをまた 明日食べたいんだからといって
今日 種をまいても　明日食べられません
明日食べたければ やっぱり 昔ですからね
やっぱり半年前に 種をまいておいて
面倒を見てあげなくちゃいけないんですね
それで ある法則が見えるんですね
そこで どんな子どもでも
一番小さい時は泣いたり
それから遊び盛りで
それから いろんなことを それなりに勉強したりとか
どんどん大人になってくると
また相手が見つかったり
家族を作ったり 仕事をしたりとかね
で 年取っていくと あまりそういうことに興味なくて
一箇所にとどまるようになったりして
どんどん死んでいく
なんか自分の希望通りではなく
違う方法で 物事が動いているんではないかと
雨が欲しい時は雨が降らないし
欲しくない時も雨が降る
時々欲しい時も雨が降る
「なんだこれ」という感じが生まれてくるんですね
そこで人間が 考えたのは
私が 私の意志で歩いているような感じで
全部の生命を管理する 管理者がいて
全部を管理しているんだと
世の中の変化やら すべてのものは その管理者に管理されているんだと
その概念から 個人の個我と真我という概念は
歴史の中でゆっくりと現れてきたんですね
それぞれの文化で その考え方は それなりに 言葉の違う説明はありますけどね
「この管理者は ある個人ですよ 神様ですよ」 という概念もある
その神様に 名前もありますけどね
誰がつけたかわかりませんけど
あるいは 個人ではなくて
「あれは真我ですよ 」という考え方もありますし
とにかく 我が 2つあることは確かなんです
私たちの個人個人が持っている我と
すべてを支配している大我ですね
大きな ātman という 2つがあるんだと
そのように言うんだけど
ひとりも証明していないんですね　あるということをね
「真我があるんだ 神様がいるんだ」と 言うだけであって
本当にあるかないかと 一度も確かめたことはないんです
一度も
ただそうやって 信じているだけ
時々 「人間には魂があるんだけど 動物にはないんだ」という人々もいますけどね
「動物には 魂は吹き込んでいないんだ」と
そう言われると よく見えるんですね 何を考えているかと
動物を殺して食べたいんですね
だから「殺すなかれ」と書いているんだけど
「それは 神様の言葉だ」と言っているんだけど
やっぱり人間というのは 殺して食べたいんですね
そこで 平気で 自分は信じているにも関わらず
「やっぱり 動物には魂がないんだ」と
「殺して食べてもいい」と
それから またあるグループでは
動物だけではなくて 人間も殺したいんですね
そこで何を言うかというと
神様を信じていない人は どうせ地獄に行くんだから
人間としては 権利はないんだと
自分を創造して管理して
自分に豊かさ 幸せを 与えてくれている 神様自体を否定しているんだから
「生きる権利はない」ということで
自分の神様を信じていない人々を
何の感情もなしに殺すと
「それで 神様は大変喜ぶ」と
人間が言うんです
神様が言うんじゃなくて
そのように いろいろ複雑な宗教やら 生き方やら
世の中に広げて 発展していたんだけど
もともと もう間違っているんですね
「私は考えている だから私はいる」 という この西洋的な考え方と同じく
もともと もう そこら辺で理屈は間違っているんです
だから 私たちにある問題は
「永遠不滅の何かが あるかないか」と 調べることなんですね
そういうわけで まず仏教は
「無我ですよ 我はありませんよ」と
他人の考え方を いきなり否定することはないんです
いきなり「あんた 間違っているんだよ」
「嘘を言っているんだ」とか言って
余計な喧嘩を作るということはない
その代わりに 「はい わかりました」
「あなたがおっしゃる 我  ātman  というものは どんなものかと調べましょう」と
調べることになったんです
そこで 調べる方法が 2つあるんです
わかりやすい方法は 分析すること
そういうわけで 仏教ではきめ細かく物事を分析する
ギリギリまで分析する
究極なところまで 物事を分析してみる
分析したところで
仏教でいう「心の教え」「物質の教え」 の2つが出来上がっちゃったんだけど
真我は 見つからなかったんです
魂は
分析するとは どういうことかというと
例えば 皆様 テープレコーダーを使っていらっしゃるんですね
もし我々は テープレコーダーの中に
「テープレコーダーたるものが ありますよ」と
いわゆる 魂みたいに
テープレコーダーは なぜテープレコーダーというならば それなりの実体
「テープレコーダーたるものが テープレコーダーの中にありますよ」と言うならば
それを分解してみればいいんです
全部 部品に
分解すれば どうなるかというと テープレコーダーは消えちゃうんです
テープレコーダーたるものは 見つからないんです
椅子という場合は 椅子たるものがあるというならば
分解してみれば いとも簡単に
違うものに変化するんですね
それで テープレコーダーたるものは 見つからなくなっちゃう
「ボールペンがありますよ」という
「ありますよ」と言ったら 一般的にはあります
でも「ボールペンたるものが何かあるんだ」と言ったならば
それはもう分解してみれば
部品にしてみれば ひとつもボールペンではありません
それで 正しい分析は した方が良かったのではないかと
で お釈迦様は 例えば 見るもの 聞くものを全部ごちゃまぜにして
「私は生きているんだ」とは 言ってないんです
人は 全部ごちゃまぜにして
「私は40 年間生きていたんだ」
「50 年間生きていたんだ」と
ずいぶん大雑把で まとめるんですね
それで 何か実体があるように 錯覚が起こるんです
そうじゃなくて 目で見えているんだと
耳で聞こえているんだと
見るものと 聞くものは まるっきり違うものだと
全く違うもの　耳で聞こえるのは音であって
目に入るのは 光の波動であって
まるっきり違うでしょうに
今 こちらに貼っているポスターは 聞くことはできないでしょうに
じゃあ 聞いてみてください
何も聞こえない それは見るものなんですね
じゃあ 聞くものは見ることできますかね？
見られません
食べるものがあったならば
その味は 食べて味わうのであって
見て これはしょっぱい
これは辛いとか 言えますかね？
見ては言えません
あるいは 聞いて言えますかね？
おにぎりなんか 耳元に持ってきて 「あ これはこういう味だ」と
ですから 耳に入る情報
口に入る情報は 全く別質なもので
それを ごちゃまぜにまとめて 私たちは生きているんだと言うんですね
それで 私という実体があると思ってしまう
勘違いが起こる それは錯覚だと
そういうわけで 私たちにとっては 分析する能力が必要になったんですね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想という この観察瞑想
物事を そのまま観察していく
それは 瞑想ではないんです
瞑想というのは 強引に何かをすることで
そうすると ちょっとおかしくて
本当か何か わからなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 強引に何か観察するという 瞑想はしないで
単なるヴィパッサナーという ありのままを観察するという方法で
分析能力を身につけるんですね
そこで ひとつ言葉を教えてあげたいんだけど
この vibhajja vāda という言葉なんですが
vibhajja というのは 「分析する」 ということ
vāda というのは 「教え」 ということなんですね
「分析する教え」という意味なんです
お釈迦様が亡くなってから
ほんのちょっと 時間が経ったところで
いろんな考え方が 仏教に入り込んだところで
問題が起きたんですね
「一体 お釈迦様は何を教えたんですか？」と
「どのように教えたんですか？」というと
お釈迦様は 分析したんだと
物事を
まぁ そういうことになって
今 上座仏教は 我々の言葉で 「テーラワーダ仏教」と言いますけど
古い言葉は Vibhajja Vādaなんです
分析するんだと
分析して 最後に何もなかったということが見つかるんだと
だから 何もなかったということが見つかるのは
覚りの境地であって
それに至るためには 「ある」と思っているものを 分析していかなくちゃいけないんですね
なんか ヨーロッパの方に ある哲学者がいてね
なんかこの モデルは天国にあるんだと
椅子の
「完全たる椅子の形のモデルは 天国にあるんだ」と
犬だったら完全な犬の形は天国にあって
「人間の世界にあるのは それなりのものだ」とも思っていたんだからね
だから そんなものは単なる空想であって
何か証拠があって 言うわけじゃないんです
体の観察はこういうことなんです
いろんな人を見てみる
見ると 似ていて 似ていない
そうでしょ？　人間というのは 我々でも
見てみれば みんな同じ人間なんですけど
みんなに頭があって 手があって 足があってとかね
胴体があったりとかね
ほとんど似ています
でも 似ていて また あえて似ていないんですね
背の高さが違うし 髪の硬さは違うし
肌の色が違うし 顔の形が違うし
目の形が違うし
まぁ いろんな違うところがあるんです
それから 人間を見ると
「あ この人こそ ぴったし人間だ」 とは なかなか言いにくいんですね
なかなか言いにくい 「あ 人間のモデルはあの人ですよ」と
「女性のモデルはあの人ですよ」と
「男性のモデルはあの人ですよ」と　そういう人間はいませんね
どんなに 我々の目から見て美しいと思う人にしても やっぱり
それなりに違うところは また持っている
変わっているところ
そこは 空想する人にとっては
やっぱり人間は 似ていて似ていないということは あるひとつのモデルがあって
そのモデルから それなりに いろんなところを
少々変えて 作ったんではないかと
作られたんではないかと
ですから 人間の世界にある すべてのものに
ぴったし ではなくて
理想的なモデルが上にあるんだと どこかに
それがある場所は やっぱり天国でなければいけませんし
地球のどこかにあるんだったら 見つかるはずですからね
我々は そういう考え方にも哲学というんですけど
それは仏教の立場から見れば
ただの空想であって 妄想なんですね
勝手にものごとを考える
何か情報があって 考えることは確かなんです
気持ちはわかります 私も
そういう人々がね 犬を見ても
犬は みんな犬なんですけど えらい違うでしょうに
小さい犬がいたり でかい犬がいたりとかね
顔が すごいグロテスクな犬がいたりとかね
すごい かわいい犬がいたりとかね
だからすごい でかい犬
なんという名前かわかりませんけど いて
それから もう膝で抱いて 飼っている 小さな犬の種類もありますけど
随分違うでしょうし
違うんだけど 犬には変わりはないんだから
それだったら 犬の基本的なモデルは どこかにあるでしょうと
空想することは 可能なんですね
そこで
そういうふうに 人間たるものとかね
我々の実体とかね
何かがあるか と ないかを 見るためには
vibhajja という分析
分けてみる
ひとつひとつ 丁寧に 分けて見ることしかない
お釈迦様は 自分が Vibhajja vādīと言ってはいなかったんですけどね
お釈迦様は 何をおっしゃるかというと
初期仏教の時代のお坊様たちに聞いたら
おっしゃったのは 「お釈迦様は 因果法則を教えたんだ」と
まぁ それ 2つもつなげていますから
そんなに差があるわけじゃないんです
因果法則も わかれば
「実体はない」ということを発見できるんです
だから 「なぜ因果法則を教えているんですか？」というと
やっぱり 虚無主義者には なれませんからね
仏教は 無我だと言っても 虚無主義なわけじゃないんです
「何もないんだ だから 平気だ」 と言っているわけじゃないんです
何もないんじゃなくて
「いろいろ原因があって それなりの現象が 一時的に生まれますよ」と
で 子どもが生まれたら 確実に立派な大人に成長するかという 約束はないんだと
子どもはどんどん変化していく
その過程で どんな原因がそろっていくかということに
立派な大人になるか だらしのない人間になるかということは
最終的に決められますからね
そういうわけで 「因果法則は 大事ですよ」と
それで 今 覚えていただきたいのは
ただこれだけ この分析
「ここに時計がありますよ」と言った途端
我々は「やっぱりそうだ 時計があるんだ」と
そこで
「そうだ 時計があるんだ」というふうに思わないで
「時計って 一体何ですか？」と
「じゃあ ひとつひとつ分析してみよう」と
分析したら 針がある
針は 時計ではありません
カバーがある
カバーは 時計ではありません
で この丸い文字盤がある
文字盤が 時計ではありません
電池がある
電池は 時計ではありません
そこで また中に 電池を動かす なんとか とか
それなりの 歯車とかありますからね
それひとつひとつも 時計ではありません
では 「時計は 時計ですか？」と
そうすると どう答えればいいんですか？
全く別々なものがある
ある法則でつなげたら
「時計」という 一時的な現象が生まれる のであって
時計はありません と
だから「時計はありません」だけ 言ったらダメなんです
「時計はありません」 だって こちらに 実際に時計があるんだから
「時計なんかは存在しません」と言ったら なんか それまた おかしい考え方で
そうじゃなくて
別々な働きをする それぞれ違うものは
ある法則によってつなげれば 時計なんですね
で 時計の
例えば これは なんとか時計
ポケットに使う時計だからね
鎖をつなげる部分がありますね
それの働きは違う
針は別に何もしない
でも 針の働きは違う
文字盤の働きは 全く違う 何もやってない
で それぞれ 歯車や電池やらね
それなりの 自分の仕事をやってるだけで
ひとりも 時間を教えてあげることは やってないんです
時計の中にある電池が そんなこと知りません
ただ電力を 定期的に出しているだけ
そこで 電力をコントロールする コイルやら いろいろね
クリスタルやら いろいろありますけどね
そちらは時計のことは 全然知りません
自分の仕事をやってるだけで
じゃあ 歯車は知ってる？
全然知りません　歯車はちょっと刺激したら 1コマ1コマ 飛ぶだけで
じゃあ 針は？
針はそれに繋げているんだから 一緒に動くだけ
文字盤は？　文字盤は別に どうといったことなく ただじーっと 待ってるだけ
だから ひとりひとりの仕事は 別々なんです
それなのに 我々には 「時計がある」という概念があるんです
だから そういうふうに分析してみると
「あぁ 時計という実体は ありません ではなくて 成り立たないんだ」と
いろいろ仕事をまとめたら
新しい仕事は生まれる
目で見たら時間を言える ということを 我々にはできます
で 車という例を見ても 同じことで
「どこが車ですか？」と聞くと
どっちでも 車じゃないんですね
車体は車ではないし 車輪は車ではないし
座席は車ではないし
燃料は車ではないし
ネジは車ではないし ミラーは車ではないし
ひとつも車ではないんです
鉄やら プラスチックやら いろいろ ものはありますけどね
ひとつも車ではありません
じゃあ 車っていうのはまるっきりないかというと そうではなくて
全く違う仕事をするものを
ある法則によって まとめたところで
「あぁ 車はあるんじゃないかな」と
ですから 車の存在は あくまでも一時的であって
ひとつの現象のみ
実体はないんです
それで さらに続けていくと
ひとつひとつ 車の部品は
「車輪があります」 と言っても
それを さらに分析すると
また違う働きの品物が 出てくるんです
例えば 車にとっては 空気は 大変大事なことで
車輪は 空気の上に
でも あの車の重さやら
全部 空気の圧力で支えているんだけど
「そんな力が空気にありますか？」といえば そうでもないんですね
じゃあ 私に 空気の上に座れますかね？
全然 座れません
落ちちゃいます
でも車に座ったら
本当は 空気の上に座っているんですけど
だから この
ひとつひとつの現象は 別々な仕事をしているんだと
それで 因果法則と無我論は 一体で
分離することはできないんです
分離して 平気で 「何もないんだ」というのは 虚無主義的で
道徳的でもないし
覚りに関係なくなっちゃう
そういうわけで お釈迦様は
単なる人の考え方を 馬鹿にしたのではなくて
丁寧に分析してみたところで
法則と それぞれの現象の働きは 別々に見つかりましたから
それで「無我ですよ 何もないんだ」と
「人々は それを わかってないんだから 我論にとらわれているんだ」と
「それをわかった人は 別に 束縛はされません」と
ですから 因果法則を理解することは また 覚りなんです
無我を理解することも 覚りなんです
で 次のポイントは ちょっと時間が経ちましたので
皆様 すごい疲れるし
一方的に喋ると
ちょっと 5 分くらい休憩いたしまして
続けて話をします どうもありがとうございます
2部に入ります
無我ということは すごく難しく聞こえますけど
それより もっと簡単な言葉があります
この anicca (アニッチャ) という言葉
それは日本語で「無常」ですね
anicca　パーリ語で アニッチャ というんです
日本語で有名な「無常」という言葉なんです
それは わかりやすい
無我にたどる道は 「無常」にあるんです
無我を体験しても 無常を理解しても また同じこと
全然 意味が違うわけじゃないんです
言葉は違いますが 意味は同じなんです
そこで もし私たちに
実体 本質 不変なもの
永遠なものが あるならば
世の中を調べると 私たちの生き方を調べると
変化しないものが 見つかるはずなんです
それまた いとも簡単に 見つかるはずなんです
もし私の体に 我があるんだと
実体があるんだと
本質たる 私がいるんだというならば
この体の中に そのものは 簡単に見つかるはずなんです
一番簡単に 一番先に
変わらないものだから
で 皆様は お魚を召し上がるんですね
魚は 口に入れちゃったら
一番簡単に見つかるのは 骨なんですね
もし 骨も入ったならば
すごい簡単に見つかるんです
口で
なぜかというと 魚の方が噛みやすい
溶けやすい 壊れやすい
骨は 魚の肉に比べると硬い
壊れにくい 噛みにくい
消化しにくい 変わらない
魚ひとつ買ってきて 自分の部屋に置いておくと
すぐ変わるのは 魚の肉の部分ですね
変わって 腐って
でも骨は 全然
これ 1年  2年経ってもそのまま
ですから 魚をさばく時も 取り出しやすいのは 骨の部分なんです
ですから まぁ ちょっとした例なんですけど
魚の体の中に 硬い
滅多なことで変化しない一部があります
瞬時に変化するのも 一部あります
そこで 一番探しやすいのは
この 滅多に変化しない 骨の部分なんです
それは 普通の理屈なんです
それで 人間に あるいは 物事に 変化しない実体があるならば
いとも簡単に それは見つかるはずなんです
見えるものであるならば 見えるはずなんです
舐められるものであるならば すぐ それを舐めているはずなんです
あるいは 聞いて発見するものだったら
それは それで発見できるはずなんです
それでお釈迦様は こういうふうにチャレンジします
「私たる 私という この存在を見てみましょう」と
「見てみたら 何を発見するか」と
全部 変化するものは 発見できますけど
変化しないものは 発見できない
そこで 自分という存在だけではなくて
客体的な社会 動植物 宇宙
何を見ても 変化はある
いつでも変化して 形は変わっていく
で そこに実体というものは 見つからないんです
ですから 「無常」は 無我の教えなんです
人間には 無我よりは 無常は理解しやすい言葉なんですね
なぜ理解しやすいかというと
世の中を見ると 我々は 覚りまで行かなくても
無常であることは もうちゃんと知っているんですね
それなりに知っているんです
本当に 鋭く世の中を見ると
あるのは無常のみだと
何かあると言いたければ どうしても
だったら 「無常」という抽象的な言葉しか言えないんです
「人間は 土から生まれて 土に戻りますよ」 という言葉がありますね
で そういうふうに 具体的な土とかね
そういうふうなことは 言いにくいんです
本当に言えるのは そういう物体ではなくて 「無常」ということ
「無常」自体は ちょっと抽象的な言葉で
無常は 別に どこかにいるわけじゃないんです
「物事は無常である」ということ
ですから 物事の本質は 「我」ではなくて 「無常」なんですね
ですから 我々の今持っている知識で
智慧で世の中を見ていると
やっぱり 無常は存在すると
無常という働きがあることは見えますね
で 無常でなければ 車は動かないんですね
車に実体があったならば 動きません
そんな人が 何かいじっただけで動くんだったら
実体ではないんだから
で 車に燃料を入れたら 燃料は燃えてしまうんですね
それで いろんな部品が動くんですね
それで車が動いた ということは成り立つんです
それ自体 無常だから 成り立つものなんです
「永遠不滅だ」と言ったら
車は どうやって ある一箇所から 他のところに移動できますかね？
そこで 「私たちは 生きている」とは どういうことかというと
ずっと変化することに 「生きている」というんです
最初は 一個の細胞で 命が始まりますけど
永遠不滅な魂があるんだったら
あの細胞は そのまま頑固として 硬くいるだけで 変化しないんです
そこで 人間は出来上がらないんですね
細胞は変化する 年を取っていく
年を取っていると これでダメだと思って
細胞は 2つに  4つに  8つに 分かれていくんですね
分裂していくんですね
分裂するためには 大量に 外から物質を受け入れなくちゃいけないんですね
1個の細胞が持っている物質数よりは
2個の細胞は 2倍持っていますから
ですから 世の中から いろんな物質をいただいて
どんどん 人間というものは 出来上がっちゃうんですね
だから 人間に何か無常たる じゃなくて
変化しない 永遠な我なんかあったら
これは 大変なことなんです
考えてみてください 魚の骨のようなもの
変化しないものが 1個の細胞の中に入っていたとすると
大きくなれませんから
それだったら 人間は大きくなっても 魂は変化しませんから
だから 人間には大きくなれなくなっちゃうんです
じゃあ 「魂も 人がでかくなると でかくなるぞ」と言ったならば それは嘘です
魂は 変化しないものだから
そういう哲学者もいるんです
「体の大きさによって 魂の大きさも変わりますよ」と
本当に よくも人間は 屁理屈を言っているんで
これは ジャイナ教なんですけど インドの
いまだに すごい信仰しているんです ジャイナ教は
ジャイナ教の教えでは
人の体の大きさによって 魂の大きさが違うんです
だから 象の魂がすごく大きくて
ネズミの魂が小さいんです
それでまた 「魂は 全知全能で 不滅で 永遠である」と言うんです
それで ジャイナ教も輪廻を信じていますね
そうすると 象が死んじゃったところで 人間にはなれないんですね
なぜかというと すごい でかい魂だから
体ぐらい大きいんだからね
あれは 人間の体に 積み込めませんから
変化しないものだからね
そういうふうに 何も考えないで
ただ 体の大きさに「魂が大きい」と 平気で言うんです
でも だからといって ジャイナ教祖様が でっち上げた嘘を言っているわけじゃないんです
彼にも 何かあって そう言っているんです
何があるかというと 私たちは これぐらい大きい体で 実感が生まれている
160センチぐらい 高いんだったら
160センチ 背が高くて
これぐらいの体で 私という実感がある
ネズミさんには これぐらい小さいんだから
それぐらいの大きさで 私という実感があると
それは事実です
象だったら すごいでかいスケールで 私という実感が生まれてくる
その足を触ったら それは 「私の足を触っているんだ」と知っているんだから
言いませんけどね そんなことは
言わないんだけど 感じることは 確かに感じる
だから この感覚なんですね
感覚が 体の大きさによって 変化するんです
アメーバみたいな 小さな動物の感覚が ものすごい小さいんです
あの体にしか 物事を感じられませんから
その感覚を 間違って その人々がちょっと誤解して
「感覚から 私がいるという 実感が生まれるんだから すなわち 我ですよ」と
だから 何のこともなく
「体の大きさによって 魂の大きさが変わりますよ」と
ということを 言ったりする
そこで 解脱したならば
ジャイナ教でも 解脱という言葉も使うし
kaivalya (カイワリャ) という言葉を使っているんですけどね
kaivalya というのは
日本訳はどうすればいいんですかね？
まぁ 絶対的状態というふうな意味
最終的な状態
最高な状態というふうな 意味なんですね
それ以上ない状態
だから 解脱という言葉よりはね
涅槃という言葉は使ってないんです
で kaivalyaという いわゆるどんな宗教でも言っている 解脱のことですけどね
「その状態になったら もう体はなくなる」と
それで 「普遍的な真我になるんだ」と
というと この魂は
随分 スケールが小さくなったり 大きくなったりするものなんですね
だから それ自体の考え方はおかしいと
おかしいというよりは
「やっぱり変化するでしょう」と お釈迦様から見れば
「あなたが おっしゃっている 魂さえも変化するでしょうし」
変化するだけじゃなくて
犬の魂が小さくて 機能は小さいと
象の魂が大きくて その分機能も大きいと
人間の魂はそれなりであって
人間と象を比べたら また機能が違うでしょうし と
そこで （他宗教は）全知のことを言っているんだからね
魂には ほんのちょっと 智慧があるんだと
すべての煩悩が消えちゃったら 一切の智慧が生まれるんだと言っているんだからね
だから 魂は ある時は ほんのわずかなことしか知らないし
ある時は すべてのものを知るように 巨大化するし
それ自体も変化でしょうに
物事を見える魂がいて
物事を見えない魂がいるんだということ自体も 変化なんです
だから はっきり無常をわかってない
だから そういうふうな考え方が生まれるんだと
そういうわけで この無常という概念は 素晴らしい概念なんです
それは ものすごい発見なんです
それを発見したんだから
お釈迦様は 「やっと発見しました」と
真理を
真理というのは 無常ということなんです
私は ずっと変化していなきゃ
「生きている」ということは言えません
食べたご飯が そのまま体の中にあったなら 私は病気なんです
お医者さんにお願いして
「食べたものが早く消えるように 何とかしてください」と
でなきゃ 私は病気で死んじゃうんです
で 食べたものは 口に入った瞬間から 変化していく
それから お腹に入ったら 腸に入ったら 全部食べ物は消えてしまう
体から何を出すんですかね？　食べたものを出しますかね？
食べたものと 全く違うものを 出しているでしょうに
そういう変化があるんだから
「私は生きているんだ」と
「元気だ」と　「よく食欲はあるんだ」と
「よく食欲がある」と言う人は
もう大量に食べても 全部早く変化して 消えるということ
「食欲ないな」と言う人は
たくさん食べても 早く変化しないということなんです
ですから ほんのちょっと食べてる
それも やっと苦労して 変化させると
だから変化自体は 生きているということなんです
光の波動が目に映ったら
目の中で変化が起こらなきゃ 見えますかね？
見えませんし
脳の中で ありとあらゆる変化が起こらなきゃ 「見えた」となりませんし
で 私は今 喋っているんだから
あの食べたご飯のエネルギーは ずっと消えていくでしょうし
消えたところで 「もう力がないんだ」 ということになるでしょうし
「子どもが 生きているんだ」ということは
子どもは ずっと変化して 生きていることなんですね
だから 変化でなければ ものは成り立たない
私は よく言う例がありまして
バイオリンというのは 楽器なんですね
そこに変化がなければ 「音が生まれますか? 」と
あのバイオリンの弦と弓と言うんですか
bow (ボウ) と 英語で言いますけどもね
弓が 触れて
空気の中に 変化を起こしちゃうんですね
それで 音楽というんです
何も変化しなきゃ そこで音楽はないんです
それだったら うるさくて しょうがなくなっちゃいますからね
ピアノやら バイオリンやら 太鼓やら ドラムスやらね
ただ そのままで音楽だったら
この世の中で いれたもんじゃないんだよ うるさいんだから
やっぱり誰かが ドラムセットにしても
変化を起こさなきゃ そこに音が生まれませんね
そこで 我々は種をまいたりする
その種は 完全に消えてしまわなきゃ 芽があるわけじゃないでしょうに
その芽は またどんどん消えて大きくならなきゃ
我々に必要な植物は 出てこないでしょうに
毎日 世の中を見ていると
瞬間瞬間 すべてのものは変化する
変化するんだから あるんですね
ですから 「ある」というならば 変化なんですね
存在というならば 変化は存在である
変化は「へんげ」と読む場合もありますけど 仏教用語でね
それぞれ 発音はどうでもいいんですけど
ですから 変化っていうのは 無常ということで
そのままではいられないんです
「時計は時計ですよ」 と言うためには
この時計は 変化しなきゃ 時計ではないんです
それだと私は 「時計壊れているんだ」と
なぜなら 時計見ると 針はそのままだったら 壊れているでしょうに
だから そこに変化が起きているんです
止まらない その変化は
そこで 電池は切れるし
そこで 時計は止まっちゃうし
それで 電気入れたら また動き始めますし
じゃあ 電気を入れないで置いておけば 時計はどうなるんですか？
それでも変化する
だから 変化だけは 止まれません
じゃあ 人間は強いて 「やっぱり何か永遠不滅なものが欲しいんだ」と言うならば
「変化は永遠不滅だよ」とは 言えますけど
それは言葉の遊びですけどね
永遠不滅なものといえば
「無常」ということは 永遠不滅だと
それを お釈迦様は言うんです
「万物は無常であることは 過去でも無常でした」と
「今も無常です」と
「これからも無常ですよ」と
だから仏教では 真理を語っているんだと
時代が変わっても 真理は変わりませんと
じゃあ 仏教は古臭いかと
今 2600年経っているんだから
お釈迦様が生まれて
あぁ 仏教は古臭いんだと
そんな古い話なんか 現代 科学時代の
インターネット時代の 通信時代の我々にはどうかと
そんなことありますかね？
そんなことはないでしょうし
無始なる過去も 物事は無常だから存在したんであって
現在でも 物事は無常だから存在するんであって
将来も そうでしょうし
だから 無常こそ 真理なんです
花が咲くのも 花が散るのも 無常だからでしょうし
植物は 今はね どんどん黄色くなっていくでしょうね　葉っぱなんかは
それは無常でしょうし
それで葉っぱが落ちて
何のこともなく じっと寝ているでしょうに　冬になったら
寝ているわけじゃないんです それでも 生きているんですけどね
それもまた 無常でしょう
それで春になってくると
一斉に 花が咲いたりし
新緑が出たりするでしょうし
そんなことを 止まってみてください
それで 死の世界でしょうに
生の世界じゃないんです
だから この人々は
「実体があるんだ」「変化しないものはあるんだ」と言う人々は あまりにも無知なんです
変化しないものがあるということは
もう 死の世界なんです
変化するんだから 世の中には生の世界 生きているんです
変化があるんだから 私は 努力しても構いません
例えば 「私には絶対的な魂があるんだ」と 思い込んじゃったら
私は何をやろうと 魂は絶対的だから 変化しないでしょうに
人を殺しても あるいは 人を助けてあげても
まぁ 魂は 知ったことじゃないんですね
変化しませんから
でも 体の中に変化しないものは ひとつもないんだから
私は悪いことをすると 悪い人間になる
いいことをすると いい人間になる
それで 今まで悪いことをしてきた人間が
「じゃあ これからいいことをしますよ」 と思ったら
それから いい人間になる
今まで いいことをしてきた人間が
「これから 悪いことをしましょう」と思ったら
それから悪い人間になってしまう
そういうわけで 変化があるんだからこそ
人間の努力の意味があるんです
人間に 希望通りのことができるんです
我々が希望通りのことをできるためには
無常でなければいけません
それなのに この我があると言っている人々は
「真我は自由自在だ」と言うんです
絶対的で 普遍的で
何て言いますか
普遍的ではなくて
永遠なもので
変化しないもので また 自由自在だと
ありえないでしょうに そんなことは
絶対的なものだから
何のために 自由自在である必要があるんですかね？
大きくなったり 小さくなったりとかね
長くなったり 短くなったりとか
そういう 自由自在になる必要はないでしょうに
絶対的なものだから
だから 世の中で 本当にもう それほど無知な考え方はないんですけど
すべての人類は 我論にいるんですね
「我があるんだ」と
そういうわけで お釈迦様が 覚ってない人に使っている言葉は 何でしょうかね？
「愚か者」という言葉を 平気で使っているんです
Moghapurisa という言葉 「愚か者」と
別に 貶している言葉ではなくて
やっぱり 「無明に覆われている人々だ」
これほど
我ほど 非合理的な 非論理的な考え方はないんです
どう観察してみても
世の中は変化に 変化の上で 変化で成り立っているんです
世の中で 変化ができなければ
どうやって 飛行機を作れますかね？
あんな何万トンも重いものが よく空を飛ぶでしょうに
変化だから 可能なんです
ものごとを
全く別な仕事をする物事を
空を飛べそうもない物事を集めて
それで 空を飛ばしちゃうんですね
千人も 人を乗せて
人の荷物まで乗せて
行くんだから 飛ぶんだから
それは 無常だから成り立つんですね
同時に 因果法則も成り立つんです
どういうことかというと
誰かが 飛行機を作る材料を 私のところに持ってきても
私が作った飛行機には 乗らない方がいいんです
それは 空を飛ぶどころか 1メートル先にも 行かないかもしれません
一番先に 運ぶためには
すごい巨大なトラックでも使わないと
なぜかというと 私は飛行機の因果法則はわかりません
だから作れません
空を飛ぶという場合は
好き勝手に 飛ぶわけじゃなくて
それには それなりの法則もあるんです
人間が 子どもを作るんだと思ったって
やっぱりそれなりの法則があるんです
その法則によって 子どもを作るんだけど
変化がなければ それでも子どもは 生まれませんね
だからその変化と 因果法則は まるっきり理解しないんだから
「全部 神様に決められているんだ」と
そこで科学者たちが 「DNA の研究をやってみよう」と
「遺伝子改変でもやってみようか 面白いぞ」と思っちゃうと
「神様の領域を侮辱するな 侵すな」と言うんですね
何の根拠で あんなことを言っているんですかね？
今まで 神様の領域を侵しちゃったんだから
このような世界があるんだから
侵したいほど 侵した方がいいんです
神様が 「やってはいけない」と言うことが 何かあるならば
必ず やった方がいいんです
そうすると 幸福になるんです
不思議な話なんですね
で 本当は 神様はそんなことを言ってるわけじゃなくて
大馬鹿者どもがね 聖書という文学作品を書いているだけであって
そこに乗っ取られて イカれているだけのことなんですけど
神様みたいな この絶対的な管理者が ありえないしね
法則によって成り立っていることを わかっていないだけで
そこで 私たちは「無常」を理解できれば
「そこに実体がない」ということが 見えてくる
じゃあ 音について考えましょう
どこかから 音が生まれてくる
音っていうのは 瞬間しか
1秒に 大体40万回でも変化しなきゃ 音ではないんです
それぐらい変化するエネルギーは 耳に触れると
それなりに 頭の中にいろいろ変化を受けて
聴覚っていうものは生まれる
それで 感覚も生まれる
考え方も生まれる
「面白い音だ」と
「綺麗な音だ」「感動できる音だ」と
「うるさい音だ」と 我々に考え方も生まれる
そこで 実体はありますかね？
そこに実体はないんです
車と同じ 花と同じく 変化の過程なんです
なぜかというと 耳に入っている音は
時々 気持ちはいい 時々 気持ちは悪い
時々は感動する 時々は腹が立つと
ただ 音が触れるだけで
ですから 感情というものも ずっと変化していますね
「私は今 泣いているんだ」と言う人は
あと時間経つと 笑っている
そこで 「私は笑っているんだ」と
その時は その人は精神的に全く違うんですね
変化しているんです
もし我々に変化しない主体があるならば
私は何を喋っても 全く変化はないはずなんです
今日 私はすごく気をつけて喋っているんですけど
もっと大胆なことを言いますけどね
今日 すごい気をつけて喋っているんです
「人の気に障ることは できるだけ控えましょう」と
そういう変化しない主体があるならば
私は何を言っても 平気なはずなんです
最近 ある人が来て 「大乗仏教を批判するな」と
僕の頭に 「あんた痛いんですか？」と聞きたかったんだけどね
「痛いんだったら こっち来るな」と
だから もう馬鹿なことを
僕は大乗仏教の人じゃなくて
正真正銘の小乗仏教というか
上座仏教の坊主だから
自分の仏教を語るしか
何を 私はキリスト教を 語ればいいんですかね？
「神様を信じたまえ」とか
皆様方は 他人の宗教を批判するのは
それはけしからんことでね
平和のために良くないし
私はそう言わなきゃいけないでしょうに
お医者さんは 人を切らなくちゃいけないんです
外科であるならば
人を切ってはいけませんと
人を切ったら 犯罪でしょう
人のお腹を切ったり 胸を切ったりとかね
切るのはいいんだけど
取っちゃうんですね 中にあるものは
犯罪もいいところなんですね
でも 外科の医者は それをやらなくちゃいけないんです
それは犯罪じゃないんです
それなのに「批判するな」と
「それは 大乗仏教の方々から見れば 大変失礼だ」と
わかってます そんなことは
私は 言われる人は どれほど馬鹿者かと
でも それを私は言えませんからね
「あぁ そうですか よくわかりました」と
それで ものは済んだんだけど
ものは済んだんだってことは
頭の中で 違う考え方はありますけどね
「なんと言うアホか」と
そうじゃなくて 言いたければ
批判するんだったら
なんて言いますか
聞く側にも 納得いくように
ただ「ダメですよ」ああだ こうだ と言うんじゃなくて
ちゃんと根拠があって 証拠を出して
批判される側にも納得いくように 言った方がいいんじゃないかと
アドバイスした方が それは立派なアドバイスなんですけど
とにかく 私が言いたかったのは
我々には変化しない主体があるならば
私は何を言っても構いません
心の中は 変化しないはずなんです
でも 私がちょっとでも気に障ることを言ったならば
やっぱり気に障ってしまって 気持ちが悪くなる
面白いことを言ったならば
すぐ面白くなって 笑ったりする
そこで もう変化でしょうに
もし 主体があるならば
お釈迦様みたいな ブッダたちが
ガンジス河の砂のごとく
砂のごとく来て 説法されても 人は覚りません
主体があるんだから 変化しない
ですから 福音というならば
「すべては無常ですよ」という言葉自体は福音なんです
「神が作ったよ」というのは不幸運ですね
不幸のメッセージ
「あなた方には どうすることもできないんだ」と
「もう作られているんだ」と
「操り人形だけですよ」と
どうってことないんだと
生命を貶しているんですね
馬鹿にしているんです
「あなたには何ができるか」と
ある そういう神様を信じている人が 私に言うんですね
「あなたにできますかね？ あなたの白い髪の毛でも 黒くすることは」
「できないでしょう だから神様は全部管理しているんだ」と
僕は 何も言わなかったんだけどね
だから聞きたかったのは
「なんで神様は 人間に嫌なことばかりやるんですか？」と
例えば 年取りたくないでしょ？ 私も年は取りたくないんです
嫌なんです 正直なところ
嫌ですけど 年を取るんですね
どうしようもないんです
それで 神様を信じる人は
「だから ほら ご覧なさい」
「あなたに何もできない」
「それは 中央的な 中央管理局で あなたは管理されているんだ」と
管理されてるのはいいんだけど
「なんで 嫌がらせばかり やっているんですか？」と
嫌がらせだけでしょうに 生きるということは
例えば 皆様方は どれほど苦労するんでしょうかね
ただ家賃払って 毎日の食べ物と 服とかね
薬とか それぐらいのことしかできないでしょうに 一生仕事しても
それも嫌がらせでしょうに
なんで そんなに苦労しなくちゃいけないんですかね 生きるために
猫みたいに 餌をもらったら
食べて また 褒めてもくれる
「いい子だ よく食べているんだ」と
なんで立派な人間に そんなことがないんですかね？
ですから
そういう
管理局で 管理されているわけでもない
「管理されている」と言われたら
それは不幸運であって 福音ではないんです
なぜならば 人間は貶されている
努力は否定している
人間に努力できれば 管理局はどうするんですかね？
例えば 日本には法律というものがあるんですね
その法律で 我々は管理されているんですね
私たちには どうすることもできないんです
いくら叫んでも 法律を犯しちゃったら
それなりに裁かれるし
それはやっぱり 管理局で管理されているんです
ちゃんと法律のことを管理する システムができているんだから
私たちとすごく仲のいい 警察のお巡りさんがいても
その同じ人が来て 私を捕まえちゃうんです 悪いことしちゃったら
「あんた 友達だからいいですよ」と言いますかね？
言いません その時は
ですから 「管理されているよ」ということ自体は
不幸運だと 私は悪口なんですけど 言いたいんですけどね
だから 我々は管理されてないこと
その代わりに 法則によって変化しているということ自体が
人間にとって福音なんですね
ですから お釈迦様は この幸福のメッセージを
ありとあらゆる人間に話しながら歩けと
無常ということは 幸福の言葉なんです
無常 すなわち無我なんです
なんで 「無常」に私は乗り移ったかというと
その方がわかりやすいんですね
無我ということは やっぱり インド的なんですね 考え方は
インド的というか アーリア系の人間の考え方ですね
いわゆる「実体は確実にあるんだ」と
「主体はあるんだ」と
日本的じゃない 日本は あるかないかも知らない
とにかく南無阿弥陀仏とか 成仏とかね
それぐらいで 大雑把に物事が済みますから
それほど 「我」を あまり気にしないだろうと思います
でも 人間だからね 日本の方々も
やっぱり何か 霊魂か 魂か
「何か変化しないものはあるんだ」とは 思っているんですね
だから 人を 死んじゃったら成仏させますからね
成仏したかどうかは わからないんだけど
「これでよかった 成仏できて」と
何の証拠もないのに やっぱり
で 自分ひとりで喜んじゃうんです
死んだ人はどうか わかりませんけど
お墓の前に 蕎麦とかね
酒 あの 何と言いますか
カップ酒とか置いて それで「よかった」と
そんな まぁ 食べるか 飲むかどうか わかりませんけど
とにかく そういう習慣から見えるのは何かというと
やっぱり おじいさんが「死んでない」ということなんですね
「おじいさんが 酒好きでしたからね お供えしましょう」と
酒好きでしたのは 生きてた人間でしたけどね
死んだものが 酒飲んで 酔っ払ってどうするんでしょうと わかりませんしね
もし幽霊になってて 酒を飲んじゃったら
とんでもないことになりますけどね
とにかく そういうことを考えずに ただ
酒好きだったら 酒をお供えするし
ご飯を好きだったら ご飯をお供えするし
なんとかする
そういう習慣の中にも やっぱり人間の感情は 入っているんですね
やっぱり 「何か続いて 変化しないものは あるんだ」と
この śūnyatā 空論の場合は
最初は 「全部幻だよ」「主体 実体はないんだよ」と
「幻覚だよ」「蜃気楼だよ」と
「頭に映る概念だけですよ」と
「現象ですよ」と
という教えでしたけど
やっぱり どんどん その空論というものが発達して
「空自体が 実体だよ」と言ってしまったんです
お釈迦さまを 普通の人だったら殺しちゃいます　その人々は
「私が言ったことと 正反対のことを言っているのではないか」と
とにかく
やっぱり人間は こういうふうに空想を続けちゃうと
最後に また実体論に 止まってしまうんです
しょうがないんですね どうしようもないんです
とにかく 我々には 「無常」はわかりやすいんだから
無常をよく理解して
(時計は この時間)
無常ということを理解すると
「あぁ 無常だから生きているんだ」
「無常だから 蛍光灯が光っているんだ」
「無常だから 私は喋っているんだ」
「無常だから 私の言うことを理解できるんだ」ということも わかるでしょうし
「無常だからご飯食べられるんだ」と
「無常だから食べたご飯は消化できるんだ」と
「無常だから 存在というこの働きがあるんだ」と
そこで問題は 全部無常だから
どこに「私は」と言うんですか？ という問題なんです
変化するんだから
そこで 今「私は」と捕まったものは
1時間経って捕まってみると 全く別なものなんです
リンゴの種をまく
そこで それはその時のもので
1年経ったところで
「前 私はリンゴの種を 手で握っていたんだよ」と
まいて 1年経ったところで握るのは リンゴの種ですかね？
全く別な 木なんですね
そこら辺を 理解できれば
覚りの境地に なんとなく 近寄る可能性はあります
だから母親は 私はよく言う 同じ例えなんですけど
母親は 産むのは赤ちゃんなんです
で 30歳ぐらいの大きな大人を見て
「お前は 私が産んだ子どもではないか」と
あれは 嘘でしょうし
あんなでかい人を 産むわけにいきませんし
産めないでしょうに
自分が産んだのは 小さな赤ちゃんであって
その人はもう変化して 全く別なものになっている
全く別なんです
そこで
「取るものはないんだ」と
例えば 自分の子どもの体の中で
「私の子はこの部分だよ」というものは 何もないんです
「赤ちゃんの体は 全部私の子どもだよ」と言っても
その体は 全部消えちゃいますから
お母さんに 子どもがなくなっちゃうんです
10歳ぐらいになっちゃうと
そこで 「因果法則」が成り立って
ひとつ変化するということは
違うものに変化する
あるいは 新しいものが生まれる
変化するということは
新しいものが生まれなきゃ 変化ではありません
それもまた ごく普通なこと
「あ これ変化しましたよ」というと
新しいものが生まれた ということなんです
例えば 壁に色を塗ったとする
で 拭かないで置いておいたら
1 年間ぐらいとかね
私たちには よく経験がありますけど
自分の国では いくら色を塗っても
3ヶ月 経ってみたところで 色がないんです
もう消えているんです
太陽の光が強いんだから
そこで 塗った青い色が変化したんです
太陽の光に当たって
変化して 違う色になった
だから変化の法則っていうのは
消えて 違うものが生まれる
生まれたものは 全く違うんです
じゃあ 米とご飯は全く同じものですか？
同じものじゃないでしょうに
米は食べられませんし
おいしくもないし
で 米から ご飯は生まれますけど
ご飯はおいしいし 柔らかいし
食べられるし 食べたら体が元気になるし
で 米食べたら 硬いし おいしくないし
食べたら お腹を壊すし
消化不良になる 食べてみてください
消化できなくなっちゃうんです
だから
ご飯の中に 米の魂が入ってるわけじゃないんです
米自体が変化して ご飯になったんです
ご飯を食べたところで ご飯は消えちゃったんです
消えちゃって 違う変化を起こしているんです
それで今 私は食べたご飯で 喋っていますけど
どんなご飯で喋っているかわかりますかね？　もうわからない
もう消えちゃったんだから
子どもは遊んでいると
まぁ 朝 何か食べさせたんだと
パンやら いろいろなものを食べ
ヨーグルトやらを 食べさせたんだと
そこで 昼は ラーメンを食べさせたんだと
そこで 子どもは 2時から 4時まで遊んでいると
2時から 2時半まで 「あれは パンのエネルギーで 遊んでいるんだ」と
2時10 分から 15分まで 「あれは卵のエネルギーです」
わかりますかね？ そんなことは
さっぱり わからないでしょうに
もう変化しちゃったんだから
もうすでに そこに何もないんです
新しいものが 生まれているんです
ですから つかまるもの
執着するべきもの
ありがたいものっていうのはないんだから
無執着の心を作ると
だからといって じゃあ 道徳は成り立たないかと
成り立つんです
なぜかというと
米がなかったら ご飯は生まれませんね
残念ですけどもね
人参を茹でても
あぁ 米になったと
だったら 世の中で どうしようもなくなっちゃうんで 無茶苦茶で
それは 無茶苦茶ではない
法則があるんです
ですから リンゴの種をまいた人は
その人だけに リンゴは食べられるし
泥棒した人が それなりに不幸になるし
誰かさんが泥棒したんだから 私がつかまることはないんです
変化の流れは 決まっているんです
そういうわけで 道徳も成り立つ 因果法則によって
そういうわけで 修行というものも成り立つ
修行しなくちゃいけない
じーっと待っていても どうにもなりませんと
他力で「救われるかな」と待っていても 意味がないんだと
特に 初期時代の宗教っていうのは
とにかくお願いする
お釈迦様が現れた時代の 宗教っていうのは
神様を褒め称える
このヴェーダ聖典っていうのは
唱えるんですからね
そこで 神様が機嫌良くなって
人々に祝福を与えてくれるんだと
人間の汚い声で 何か言っただけで 機嫌が良くなる神様だったらね
どう見ても ろくな神様ではないんだけど
それだったら 神様はね
人間の褒め称える 賛美歌を聞いて喜ぶのだったら
世界一流のプロを頼んで 賛美歌を歌わせなくちゃいけないでしょうし
そんなことじゃなくて おばあさんもおじいさんも
喉が まるきり音痴な人も 歌うんだから
で 神様は大変喜びましたと
笑っちゃいますけど しょうがないんですけど
とにかくこのお釈迦様の時代で あったのは そういうふうに
この神様を褒め称えることなんですね
主にあった修行法というのは
それでは 心は清らにならないんだと
自分で励みましょうと
自分で励んだところで なんでよくなるかというと
無常だから よくなるんです
無常だから よくなるはずなんですね
実体があれば 無常にはならない
ですからお釈迦様は
無我という概念を後で作った というより
後で使わずにいられなかったんだけど
それは 「すべては ダイナミズムであって 変化していて 無常ですよ」という
同じ言葉なんですね
それで ヒンドゥーの人々は インド文化の人々は
「やっぱり 何といっても 何かあるんじゃないかな」と囚われていたんだから
お釈迦様は強大に ものすごく 何と言いますか
爆発的に 爆弾でも落とすような感じで
「囚われるものは 何もないんだ」と
「全部 捨てろ」と言ったところで
あの 5人の比丘たちは 覚ったんですね
で そこら辺で話を終了させていただきますけど
来月も同じテーマは 続きますので
来月は お釈迦様が この 5人の比丘たちに教えた経典に基づいて
無我論について もっとわかりやすいと思いますけどね
説明いたします
どうもありがとうございます